are Americans trashing the English
language
The Economist's language expert Lane
Green knows a thing or two about English
this is lanes office these are some of
the books he might review Lane is a fan
of words lots of words what interests me
is the history of the words where they
come from and Lane is an American living
in London he's become accustomed to
British English slang harbors of Bo's
are that's what we're or car is a motor
but Lane often hears Britons complain
there are too many American words and
expressions creeping into British
English there are some expressions that
I don't like okay that's a good example
do the math most British people are of
course polite enough not to mention
their feelings about American English
directly to me but I do see a general
dislike of American words and American
phrases these are cooled Americanisms
originally Americanisms were four things
that were found in the Americas by
British and other colonists and settlers
things like moccasin canoe but over time
Americanisms came to refer to words that
arose in America and later entered
British English as new words
the Queen's English seems to be giving
way to the Yanks English so some people
that represents the gentle decline of an
old idea of Britain British writer
Matthew Engel we can't stand
Americanisms being used in Britain and
even wrote a book about the grassroots
spin-doctors lobbyists slush funds
everything conspires to make the world
speak the language of the world's
dominant country that is a step to a
rather homogenized and boring world
American spellings derive entirely from
the opinion of one man Noah Webster was
an American Dictionary writer a
lexicographer it was Webster who decided
that words like Center should be spelled
with an ER rather than with the re he
took the you out of words like color
words like music were then still written
with an icy K he decided that K could go
there was a huge peak in the 1930s after
Hollywood came in it became immensely
cool to speak just as the movie stars
dead now them have 24-hour television
and coming out of 500 channels you have
the Internet something that had been
manageable has become completely
overwhelming certainly now Americanisms
are entering British English and they
are influencing the language you might
hear people talking about fries instead
of chips but ah Americanisms thrashing
British English
according to Lane many of these American
words are actually British in origin we
took Lane out to pound the sidewalks of
London to see if Londoners knew the
origins of their words won't you call
this that we're walking on right now
Pitman okay now I said the word sidewalk
what would that make you think of
America I hold it a pavement okay if I
said sidewalk what would that make you
think of America sidewalk is an obvious
Americanism except that it originated in
Britain it was being used already in the
early 1800s to describe the footpath
along the Westminster Bridge if I said
someone was mad what would that make you
think of probably insane insane but if I
if I said they were angry and that's how
they were mad mad yeah that makes me mad
that's a pure American usage man meaning
angry goes all the way back to at least
about 1400 according to the oxford
english dictionary
matthew is not impressed with this
argument he thinks that once British
words go to America they should stay
there if someone whose ancestors
emigrated to America centuries ago they
can't turn up at Heathrow and say I'm
British let me in strangely though for
an American Lane is more sanguine about
the future of our native tongue British
English is in very very good and healthy
shape languages change at every level
and they do it all the time the adoption
of new words is a sign of a rich
evolving language we have our own
dialect within different parts of
England especially London we
caught me right miss lane for example I
like America
and they say there is by language they'd
have [ __ ] around people like
belonging to groups that make them
different that is certainly true British
English and this is another reason why I
don't see British English or any other
kind of English being blandly
homogenized into one global mostly
American variety of the language far
from trashing the English language
Americanisms are enriching the way in
which we speak whichever side of the
pond
you're on
you